in the end the calling card of storm
eunice was its devastating wings
with record speeds of up to 122 miles
per hour
much of britain felt the force of
eunice's temper
whipping up seas as it hit the coastline
and causing multiple fatalities from
falling trees
but essential travel had been advised
and this was why
on the m4 in south wales alari was
unable to withstand the horrendous
weather leaving the authorities little
option but to close key routes
this is thought to be the first time
both bridges between england and wales
have closed
shut down by the severity of the
windstorm eunice has brought with her
it was such a spectacle the empty m4
towards the seven bridge drew sightseers
as they predicted
history took a battering
it fell off
those left to clean up the debris of the
church spire never dreaming it would be
destroyed it's quite a symbol of our
community and so we're just feeling
short that this happened but equally
we're feeling very thankful that nobody
was hurt
rooftops peeled away as easily as the
opening of a tin can
this one landing on a railway line in
oxfordshire
train lines had pretty much shut down in
anticipation of the storm
the disruption from an event of this
magnitude
may last for a couple of days while we
clear up and sweep up and get everything
back
back working so there's going to be a
lot of
disruption but those inconvenienced got
a taste of why their journeys were
delayed we bought the tickets
back in december but nobody could
foresee that
we were worried about
goodness me
well i'm glad i'm indoors anyway it's
much safer here
planes struggled to land at heathrow
there have been problems at all major
airports
in amsterdam stranded passengers trying
to get back to the uk appeared resigned
to the ferocity of the storm i do want
to get home i do want to get home safely
though um
48 hours of data isn't really an ideal
situation i'd just like to share that
news with my wife
the winds caused damage to buildings and
iconic landmarks around the uk
with london's first ever red severe
weather warning in the event a large
chunk of the roof of the o2 arena was
torn off
in scotland there was heavy snowfall but
widespread flooding seems to have been
averted because those high winds didn't
in the end coincide with high tides and
that was a stroke of luck it actually
meant that we didn't see some of the
floods that we had feared
it was predicted to be the worst storm
in 30 years it certainly packed a punch
but failed to cow absolutely everyone
lisa holland sky news south wales